- [Voiceover] Hello David.
- [Voiceover] Hello Kim.
- [Voiceover] So today what we're doing
is taking a look at this speech
by one of my favorite Presidents,
Franklin Delano Roosevelt which he gave
at his inauguration in 1933.
And I think what's really important
about looking at a speech like this
is not only that we can
learn to analyze this
as a primary source, which will be helpful
for thinking about it historically,
but also because I
think it's really useful
to be able to look at
a Presidential speech,
or a speech given by any politician,
and understand what kind
of claims they're making
and how they're making them.
- [Voiceover] So, Kim,
before we go any further,
what even is a primary source?
What's the difference between a primary
and a secondary source?
- [Voiceover] Great question.
So a primary source is a document
that takes a look at an event
from the perspective of
someone who was there.
So, a primary source
could be lots of things.
It could be a photograph
taken by someone who was, perhaps,
attending a political rally.
It could be a diary of, maybe,
someone who was active in
the women's rights movement
in the 19th century.
Certainly any speech,
or even, let's say, like a
oral history conversation,
and I've mentioned a lot
of significant things here,
but it also doesn't even
have to be something that is
connected with a significant
person or a famous event.
It could be a shopping list, right,
if you are studying the consumption habits
of someone who lived in the 1950's.
What they bought at the grocery
store would tell you a lot
about what they ate,
what they could spend.
So, a primary source is
kind of the real meat
of research material that
shows you what people,
at the time, were thinking.
- [Voiceover] Okay, so a
primary source is an artifact
left behind by someone who was there.
- [Voiceover] Exactly.
- [Voiceover] What is a secondary source?
- [Voiceover] So a secondary
source is an interpretation.
So, say I'm a historian,
which I happen to be.
- [Voiceover] Oh my goodness!
(laughter)
What a coincidence.
- [Voiceover] So I have
done the work of digging up
a bunch of primary sources, and, then,
you look at all of them and
see what they have in common,
for example.
So maybe I'm writing
about Abraham Lincoln,
and I get a lot of photographs of Lincoln,
I get a lot of writings by
Lincoln and his contemporaries
and I go through all of them and I come up
with my interpretation
of what was going on
in Lincoln's life.
So, I write a book on Lincoln by Kim.
- [Voiceover] Until now...
(laughter)
- [Voiceover] And that's
my interpretation.
- [Voiceover] Okay.
- [Voiceover] Right?
So the things that I'm interested in
say Lincoln's religion, or lack thereof,
might not be the same things
that another historian
would be interested.
Say, they're interested in
Lincoln's foreign policy.
So, my interpretation is just one way
of looking at those primary sources
where another historian might have
a completely different interpretation.
What's also important
about secondary sources is
that I wasn't there, right?
I never talked to Lincoln.
He, you know, died more than
100 years before I was born,
which means that you can
only trust me so much.
You can, instead, maybe
get a much clearer picture
of what Lincoln was really thinking
by reading his own words.
- [Voiceover] So, trust secondary sources
about as far as you can throw them?
- [Voiceover] Well,
maybe trust all sources
about as far as you can throw them, right,
because everyone at every time
has their own perspective.
And so, the ideas of someone
who lived in the 19th century
are gonna be different than the ideas
of someone who lives now,
and you only know as much
as you can know, right?
You're only as informed as
the information that you have.
So, you really have to take
everything with a grain of salt
and compare it with other
sources from its time period,
and other sources later on, to get a sense
of what's important.
- [Voiceover] So you're
saying that you might have
a different perspective on Lincoln
than another Lincoln scholar, but
that Lincoln's writings,
themselves, also contain
Lincoln's own biases from his lifetime.
- [Voiceover] Right.
- [Voiceover] Okay, so what are we doing
with Roosevelt's Inaugural Address, here?
- [Voiceover] All right.
So, let's take a look at
this Inaugural Address
as though we're historians, right?
We're gonna sit down and
really get into the...
- [Voiceover] The feeling
of the Great Depression?
(laughter)
All right.
- [Voiceover] We're gonna get depressed.
- [Voiceover] All right, I'm ready.
So we've determined that
because he was there
and because this is a
speech delivered by him,
that this speech of
Franklin Delano Roosevelt
is a primary source.
- [Voiceover] Right, and
it's a great way to look
at the Great Depression, right?
If we want to know what
people are thinking about,
it's very important to
see what the President
of the United States has to
say when he's been elected.
So David, I know that you've
been dying to read this
in your terrific impression of Roosevelt,
so I'm gonna turn it over
to you to get a sense
of what Roosevelt has to say.
- [Voiceover] Okay, I'm gonna
scoot back from the mike.
"I am certain that my
fellow Americans expect
"that on my induction into the Presidency
"I will address them with
a candor and a decision
"which the present situation
of our people impel.
"This is preeminently the
time to speak the truth,
"the whole truth, frankly and boldly.
"Nor need we shrink from
honestly facing conditions
"in our country today.
"This great Nation will
endure as it has endured,
"will revive and will prosper.
"So, first of all, let
me assert my firm belief
"that the only thing we have
to fear is fear itself -
"nameless, unreasoning, unjustified terror
"which paralyzes needed efforts
"to convert retreat into advance."
- [Voiceover] That was
beautiful (laughter).
Thank you so much.
- [Voiceover] You're welcome.
- [Voiceover] All right.
So how do we analyze
this as a primary source
and as a speech.
And I think the first thing we want to do,
step one if you will, is just
identify what's going on, and
thankfully, that's pretty
easy for us, right now.
- [Voiceover] Right, this is a
speech given by the President
of the United States in the moment
that he becomes President.
- [Voiceover] Right,
so we know when it was,
in March 4th, 1933.
We know who gave this speech,
Franklin Delano Roosevelt,
just about to be inducted as President.
We know why he gave it,
right, very important
for Presidents when they take office
to make an Inaugural Address.
So, we've got some basics here.
We can even infer from
the Inaugural Address
where this was given,
right, in Washington D.C.
All right so in our identification,
we've got that it's a
speech, it's in D.C.,
happened in 1933, by FDR.
So that's our identification stage.
So to get at a little
deeper level for this,
let's move on to a second step
which would be, kind
of giving some context.
So it's 1933. What's going on?
- [Voiceover] Let's see.
So, the Great Depression has
been going on for four years.
- [Voiceover] Uh-hmm.
- [Voiceover] Prohibition
has not ended yet, right?
- [Voiceover] Right.
- [Voiceover] Repeal has not come,
so liquor is still illegal
in the United States,
for sale and transport.
There's massive unemployment.
The Dust Bowl is still raging.
America is not in the greatest place!
- [Voiceover] No, it's a depression,
and it's a depression in
all sorts of ways, right.
People are emotionally depressed
and there's an economic depression.
All right, so we've got
the general gist now
that this is a speech from 1933
confronting the Great Depression.
So let's get into a little
bit more of the specifics.
What is he actually talking
about in this speech?
- [Voiceover] Well, if
you look at this speech,
you can kind of see
that he's acknowledging
that things are bad.
- [Voiceover] Right.
- [Voiceover] Right. It's
time to speak the truth.
So he keeps talking about how, you know,
"It's time to speak the truth.
"We'll address the American
people with candor.
"It is time to speak the
truth, the whole truth,
"frankly and boldly.
"We will not shrink from
honestly facing conditions
"in the country today."
So Roosevelt is really
priming everyone to say,
"Like okay, you have
not been told the truth
"from your head of government
for the longest time,
"and now it's time to deal frankly
"with just how bad things have gotten."
And what's interesting, is that he says,
"Things are not, you know, great,
"but in every dark hour
of our National life
"a leadership of frankness
and vigor has met
"with that understanding and support
"of the people themselves
which is essential to victory."
And he's saying that
there's no need to be afraid
of anything except just malaise.
He's saying that Americans
need to meet the problem
of the depression with like an
up-welling of national will.
- [Voiceover] Right, and I
think, you know, it's nice
that he's saying, "Look, I'm
gonna tell it like it is.
"Things are bad.
"I recognize that things are bad."
And that's pretty important,
because up until this point,
Herbert Hoover hadn't really
done much to recognize
that things were bad.
You know, he saw that people
were suffering, and, yet,
he said this is not
necessarily the responsibility
of government to deal with this crisis.
- [Voiceover] So Roosevelt,
actually, calls it,
"a dark hour of our National life."
Right, like this is an acknowledging
that things are not great is
a big part of this speech.
But he's also saying
that it's possible for us
to bounce back if we are
honest about the problems,
and we address it with vigor,
and that is kind of the New Deal, right,
is addressing the problems honestly
and with national exuberance.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, and I think
this is such a fascinating speech
because, for one thing,
this phrase has kind of come
into our national lexicon, right.
"There's nothing to fear but fear itself,"
which is kind of strange.
It's one of those things,
like "Have your cake and eat it too."
That you're like, "Wait
how is that possible?"
So, what does he mean by,
"The only thing we have
to fear is fear itself."
- [Voiceover] I think he's saying
that this is no time to panic,
and that the only thing
that we should be afraid of
is unreasoning terror.
We shouldn't be running
around like chickens
with our heads cut off.
Right, like this is the time to stand firm
against nameless terror and
focus on making the problems
that we are facing into small,
like accessible, combatable chunks.
- [Voiceover] I think that
another thing that's important
about what he's saying there is
that the Great Depression
is caused by something
that is very new in American culture,
which is the stock market.
And the stock market
doesn't play by the rules
of straight supply and demand.
Instead, they play on confidence.
And so, the reason that
the stock market crash
of 1929 happens is because
people stopped having confidence
that stocks are worth as
much as the stock market
says they are.
So, everyone pulls out.
There's a panic, and global banking
pretty much collapses.
And that's a really hard
thing to deal with, right?
I mean it's not like
you're taking your money
out of the bank or me taking
my money out of the bank
at any one time could cause
an international depression.
- [Voiceover] Right.
- [Voiceover] But when
there is a large group
of people who all get
panicked at the same time
and take their money out of the banks,
the banks fail.
- [Voiceover] Right, and so
what I think Roosevelt is saying
is that we cannot allow
a sweeping wave of panic
to come over the nation again.
- [Voiceover] Exactly.
- [Voiceover] So, that's
the context for this speech
is things are bad.
The reason things are bad
is because of this wave
of nameless, unreasoning,
unjustified terror,
and "America, I need your support
"to make sure we don't
let that happen again,
"so we can turn this
retreat into an advance."
- [Voiceover] In our
next video, we'll go more
into how we can analyze this source
and use it to construct
an argument of our own.